deep beneath the earth something is
gearing up to explode it shoots boiling
hot liquid up in the air as high as 160
meters nope these aren't volcanoes
they're geysers usually people stay
hundreds of meters away from geysers but
what if we got a bit closer and fell
right into one what makes these geysers
so hot what's inside of them and how
would your body react if you fell into
one this is what if and here's what
would happen if you fell into a geyser
geysers are like hot springs under
intense pressure they cause eruptions
and send steam and water hundreds of
meters into the air and they're quite
rare there's less than 1000 of them
around the world and if you're not
careful these things could cause some
severe damage they've killed more than
20 people so now that we know geysers
are dangerous obviously our next step is
to send you right into one first you'd
need to choose which geyser you'd want
to fall into there's some of Iceland
Russia and lots in America and when we
say lots we mean it about one-third of
the world's geysers are located in
Yellowstone National Park so you may
want to go there regardless of which
guys are you end up falling into the
results would all mainly be the same
yeah as soon as you fall into the geyser
your skin would react to the incredibly
hot water Old Faithful in Yellowstone
has been measured at ninety-five point
six degrees you would feel an immense
amount of pain and it's safe to say that
this would be the most intense burn
you've ever experienced you'd be in
agony from a full thickness burn with
all three layers of your skin affected
first your top layer skin would start to
burn
then your blood vessels would burst your
under layers of skin would lose their
water and turn black causing them to
feel leathery and any fat you might have
would quickly bubble and be melted off
what's left of your body might then be
shot up into the air as a geyser can
erupt its water every couple of hours so
all the tourists visiting the skies er
would see your body as it goes up and
then back down and then up and then back
down again after the eruption your body
might fall to the bottom of the geyser
what would you find down there well
geysers have a long tea with roots and
side pockets that run deep into the
crust of the earth so at the bottom
you're going to find magma which is what
makes the water so hot the water and the
steam would build up in the loops and
side pockets and after it reaches a
boiling point of around 100 degrees at
sea level the geyser will erupted yet
again now if you somehow managed to
survive all the burns and being thrown
about by the geyser you'd still have
even more to worry about that's because
most geysers have extremely acidic
waters and combined with the high
temperatures there's a good chance
they'll be able to dissolve your body
entirely within just a couple of hours
so yeah these things are beautiful and
you might want to get a closer look but
it's best to stay further away from
getting too close can prove to be deadly
what's something that we could fall into
that we could actually survive maybe
falling into a pool of spent nuclear
fuel rods well we'll leave that story
for another what-if
[Music]